so today's video uh this video went
viral everyone was reacting to the short
clip
uh and so we decided to play that for
you guys then we're gonna play the
extended version
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it
the advice is ma'am you're average
looking at best
why can't you just get a man that's an
average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in
well then you're gonna then you're gonna
die alone how about that all right let
me just cut to the chase man
uh you can feel like what you want to
but women like you die alone
straight up i think a lot of people had
a problem with this tone
i decided to go watch the video in its
entirety just to understand
yeah where he's coming from he's doing a
a call-in with viewers where they call
in and basically disagree with things
that he said okay so what's your
disagreement
um honestly i don't have a disagreement
i just came here because i honestly want
some advice from you
it says disagreement day i know but this
is my first time catching on live
normally i'm asleep
he's like well this is my business honey
like what are you doing
you know i'm supposed to run this to my
viewers as a disagreement session
what is this and she's like ah but
samuel like i run my own business
well if you run a business then why
would you insult me by not paying for my
services
and waste my time but he's like you know
what i'm gonna entertain you just to be
nice for today so that's how the
interview
starts but he cheapened himself and
that's the reason of his tone
partially yes i definitely agree go
ahead okay from that point on he asks
her a plethora of questions if you look
at the first 10 minutes
she sounds quite goofy and he
throughout the process just asking her
straight up questions all right and at
one point
i think i took issue with two things
that he said he like you mentioned about
like see this is the problem with black
women y'all don't know how to take
advice i'm like
where did that come from i don't know
yeah that was i i agree yeah so
those are two times i was like what i
want to know at what point when i'm
just meeting a guy do i tell him that
i'm a business owner because
um my problem is that when i try to
date down and i the conversation comes
up to where i
own the business um the guy is either
like
hey can i come join in on you on that
business
and i'm i'm learning that maybe i need a
high value man what kind of men are you
dating
i try to get guys that's not on my level
a chance
what do you mean on your level that's
making six figures or more
i honestly want a six figure guy okay
why do you need a man making six figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not is not working
out
what does it have to do with money
because i
feel like um i need a guide that i can
respect and admire and i'm a [ __ ]
invention
and i want a guy that has that drive
too she feels like she can respect
someone who's more ambitious and who
makes more
but if they make less therefore she
looks down on them
and they're less to be less respected it
was just interesting
because i'm like do you not recognize
that the way that you view the rich
person
and you you the poor person is the way
the rich person views you
that interested me a lot and the second
this idea that just because you make
money you're inherently ambitious is
crazy to me
like ambition and money are not
necessarily linked
you could be a lazy doctor who makes a
lot of money
and you could be uh someone who works in
leather
and make only 60 grand a year and be top
at your job
it varies this link that we have between
ambition and money to me is crazy
just say that you want someone who's
successful is going to provide you a
comfortable life
but it's not because someone's at their
nine to five and they're busting their
ass
off every day and they get to manager
that they're somehow less ambitious
than someone who runs their own business
we i think we put this
title on entrepreneurship and we make it
sound like having a job is somehow like
lesser than or you don't have ambition
or money or that ambition's always
linked to cash it's it's not the case so
i think we have to kind of get out of
these uh ways of thinking
and i think we over value owning your
own business a little bit too much
she goes that's why i want and when i
didn't remember
beneath my level the problem is that
they always want to get involved with my
business
and they want to help me run my business
when i try to
date down and i the conversation comes
up to where i
own a business um the guy is either like
hey can i come join in on you on that
business
what value can i bring to a man i can
help him with his business
the other thing also she said is he he
gets to one point he says okay well
listen
are you around people who make six
figures or more do you encounter these
people
do you see them on a regular basis do
you have any ways of meeting them she
says no no so
then how do you think you're going to
meet them he says it kindly at first
yeah absolutely the clip that you saw is
two-thirds in after she's not listening
to anything that he says
yes right and he says to her well how
are you going to meet this person
you don't know any men on this level you
don't know where to go
get them you don't know what they want
but you're still saying
pick me they don't want mid 30 year old
baby mamas
are trying to be polite man but they
don't want those
i ask you a question did you hear what i
said
yes why is that so okay go ahead
go ahead uh and you yourself have said
that you look
fairly average she rated herself a five
four what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten you cannot use
seven
what i rate myself five but when i put
myself together six
okay so that makes you if you give
yourself a five
that's average yes so
average looking women tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men and look
it's not pleasant to say but it's not
like this man called her and be like no
[ __ ] in case you didn't know
you ugly he didn't he didn't ugly
you ain't got no eyebrow you ugly right
right he didn't
go out of his way she called his show
she asked for advice and she asked for
free advice yes
and she asked it to be broadcast right
now and he says it too at one point
i won't do this publicly like hit me up
on a private session and then we can set
up this payment so can we say that this
is self-inflicted
how do you want me to feel bad for
someone who went to ask questions that
they wanted answers to or claimed to
repeatedly was rude throughout the
process like i was really blown away
when this girl was asking questions
and literally like there's a camera bro
and this girl pulls up her phone and
starts looking at her phone and typing
her phone
as this man is taking time to talk to
her free
who the f raised you you came on this
show
when it wasn't the right segment you
decided to waste
my time asking all kinds of questions
that you need help with
and then you don't even listen to the
things i'm saying to you free
i'm not saying kevin samuel is a good
coach i'm not saying he's a great i
don't know
i don't know nothing about him no i
don't know none of that what i am saying
is
from a basic manner standpoint how does
it make sense
it like be like me going to a pizzeria
there's a lineup i get in there
then they're like what kind of pizza
would you like i'm like actually i'd
like a box of donuts
and like we don't really make those and
they're like but i'd like a box of
donuts and i've heard you've made good
great donuts in the past
so you start making the donuts and
you're like what would you like on your
donuts and the person is just like
and there's a whole lineup of people
behind wouldn't you think that person is
trash
right so i'm sitting here confused right
i'll let you go first what are we doing
okay what did you think about his uh the
the whole clip
he was blunt he was straightforward
uh i'm biased because that's my kind of
way of talking
when if you ask for advice that's a bit
i'mma be straight up with you i'm gonna
be telling you the truth like that so i
thought he was real
at the end he got annoyed i understand
that because when you're calling
somewhere and the person is just like
i want some advice and the person is not
listening to advice or just
not showing interest and not even
acknowledging or listening
it's like you don't really want advice
you just want to talk and me to agree
with you
no that's not a good idea and i give you
points why it's a good idea but
you and you're disregarding everything
i'm telling you
and you bring your points and you're
basing yourself on feelings not on facts
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be harder
for me to have a conversation with you
yeah i think the general problem like
beyond this girl's like weird dating
wants and
and his harsh advice like i think the
main thing i took away from this is that
one you shouldn't react to short clips
because they don't give you the full
when you watch this clip in his entirety
this girl really comes off as extremely
goofy
is he rude by the end yes because by the
time he hangs up on her
she's already been not listening and
staring at her phone the whole time
so i mean at the end of the day just
folks gotta learn how to act better
it's like to me like did you say certain
things wrong
yeah sure but i really thought she was
the one who's in the wrong in this
circumstance like and it's hold on i'm
gonna give i may give him
like like i said before he cheapened
himself
he did something that was out of his
like that he wouldn't
normally do he wouldn't normally
i'm not saying i didn't excuse her but
he has sessions when
he asked for payment normals any
and he disregarded all that he didn't do
it in private
he he it was the wrong segment it was
not the right time
he didn't ask for a payment for this it
was mo
some of his time and he did all that he
and when you do all that
you feel cheaping you do feel cheap and
whenever you
okay i'm gonna i'm not gonna do that and
i'm gonna and at the end of the day it
bites you back in the ass
it it it makes you more irritable
but it's a bit of your fault yeah so i i
i just i was interested that everyone
was getting mad at him for his tone and
stuff like that like
it's like whenever you send those
pictures you pictures of yourself yeah
on reddit with a roast me
can't be mad if they annihilate you
that's it
and i think it you know what it feels
like it's like when your friend comes to
ask you for advice but they're not
asking for advice they just want you to
back up what they already think about
themselves yeah
they want you to be their cheerleader
but whenever whenever you tell them the
truth and they act all like incredulous
whenever i got friends like that
you as a friend you have to before i was
just giving advice
you have to understand what they want do
you want to just
invent vent or do you actually want
advice
if you try to give advice to someone
that vans
yeah just stop just stop it's just not
worth it
yeah he says why would these men watch
you considering all these negatives that
you have said well listen i make a lot
of money
and i'm i can plant really good and
can bring balance to his life planting
like who gives it she can't plant
she yeah she's planting she's good at
planting like gardens like
and the other thing she's like i make
money you have to understand what
men value women isn't necessarily always
women value in men
men traditionally don't look at women
who make lots of money and think that's
super hot
it's it's not it's not part of the value
system
her problem is that she's expecting her
from others
because she likes something she expects
others to like something yeah that is
not necessarily the case right
that's that's often not the case exactly
most often and that's with anything in
life it's not because
you're someone who values integrity that
you should expect that in everyone else
it's not because you don't eat the line
that you can't expect the lie not to eat
you
anything else makes sense all right well
listen uh we want to hear you guys
thoughts on this video do you guys think
he went too far did you think she went
too far what were your thoughts on
the whole thing um leave that in the
comments below
[Music]